tél
[Musique]
et
bah moi j'arrivais pas décidé avant le
tour mais d'autres et mon choix je crois
que vous êtes mes préférés vous avez la
plus belle voix et et puis vous êtes mes
préférés quand on est gardien
je crois que je choisis vous monsieur
bricolage
c'est une bonne question
allez mutual et yahia et avec tout le
monde et avec tous les yoleurs qui
supportent tout le monde tape as fait
ton choix je crois que le choix va être
difficile ils sont tous ce sont tous des
héros de grands athlètes et cette
deuxième étape s'annonce vraiment pas
car le mot c'est bien beau de supporter
les yoleurs c'est vrai c'est des super
sportif mais nous on a un magazine a
présenté exactement il vient l'étape
allez c'est parti parti
[Musique]
m
sabia today to say that from my 28 1000e
tu es très bien et toi tu perds s'y
faire soyez les bienvenus vous regardez
quatre premières le magazine consacré au
tour de la martinique en yole ronde
pendant toute la semaine tous les jours
nous serons ensemble au coeur de
l'ambiance est au coeur de la course de
kart
la deuxième étape est parti d'ici du
prêcheur pour aller vers le carbet il
grande arrivée en fanfare à nouveau ici
au prêcheur hier c'est plus fr showfloor
qui a remporté la première étape
les écarts étaient très serrés que s'est
il passé aujourd'hui les détails d'un
coup cela
[Musique]
les relief abrupt du nord caraïbes des
conditions de vent incertaine à terre on
affine les stratégies on prépare
minutieusement un parcours modifié à la
dernière minute une régate pas si calme
que sur le papier
[Musique]
une deuxième étape transformer en
triangle olympique entre le prêcheur
saint-pierre et le carbet départ donné
comme il ya repreniez télescopage cette
fois ci entre tania chaussures et zita
devant rosette/orange fa7 et des âmes et
la lanterne rouge ce même prennent un
bon départ
dès les premières minutes félix mérine
annonce la couleur le patron de caracoli
place une attaque au vent de rosette
bluff ou véritable intention affichée le
reste de la course le dira en attendant
cgf qui prend la direction des
opérations christophe d'aidé visiblement
re motiver après la double sanction
d'hier à bari + pénalité mais pas
question pour à cause de la laisser
filer
un premier duel robert francois
décidément les jours se suivent et se
ressemblent à quelques détails près
cette fois-ci cgf à qui embarque de
l'eau laissant filer son rival détenteur
du tour mais l arme fatale va trouver
sur son chemin un adversaire jusque là
discret le vent qui force qui est
compliquent la navigation en bon patron
a co dirigé les opérations mais la bouée
à virer à saint pierre est plus
intéressant brasserie lorraine ne l'a
pas oublié plus près de la côte
laguiole est la première à aborder la
marque de parcours au prix de multiples
manoeuvres fastidieuse
[Musique]
mais réussi
derrière lui tu assassines entre
robertin et franciscain aux prises trois
embarcations rosette/orange gfk et ufr
et pendant que les deux premières sont
occupés à se contrôler coup de maître de
félix mérine en fin tacticien le vieux
loup de mer prend l'intérieur de la boue
et un dépassement digne d'une course
automobile le ton à donner des tapes va
se jouer dans les petits détails mais
surtout au rythme des coups de pagaie
car plus fr
rosette orange et gf1 caraïbes n'ont pas
dit leur dernier mot
[Musique]
à la bouée numéro deux du carbet
lorraine est sous pression
ufr a distancé ses poursuivants t vient
titiller le leader de la course jusqu'à
n'en faire qu'une bouchée
le vent forcit à mouvaux rosette/orange
embarque du poids à bord de la gueule
[Musique]
l'armé fatale quoi encore la victoire
l'équipage lutte contre vents et marées
se fait peur avec des rafales
aco a soif de champfleur il veut la tête
de merine mais c'est sans compter sur la
détermination du fr la godille imprime
sa marque sur l'eau
l'équipage entame le deuxième tour de
parcours en tête
[Musique]
une nouvelle boucle au cours de laquelle
rosette orange ne réussira jamais à
menacer ufr de retour au prêcheur
accords acp baud discuter de toutes les
stratégies possibles avec son équipage
ufr ira chercher sa victoire à la force
des bras
et de deux pour l'équipage de caracoli
[Musique]
puis fr champions s'offre donc une
deuxième étape devant rosette/orange
deuxième une minute trente six secondes
brasserie lorraine troisième à 5 minutes
51 secondes
ce même quatrième saut marek petit
navire 5e
comme il ya un bon comportement de
laguiole sans sponsor avec du vent qui
finit 6e en revanche contre-performance
pour les frères masse laguiole 10e
mutuelle mare gaillard tania chaussures
smsr et royal fruit de martinique
adeptes tous trois remorques et à
l'arrivée termine classement avec un
handicap de deux heures 17 minutes et 11
secondes ufr chanflor confirme son
maillot rouge de leader rosette orange
reste au contact à 11 minutes 51
secondes devant brasse et lawrence 1 à
3e à 12 minutes 22 secondes
ce marek petit navire est quatrième à
edou vent occupe une très méritante
cinquième place
ce même montre la moitié du classement
mais reste un une heure 25 minutes du
leader
en deuxième partie de classement on
retrouve nos titan brico bat 11e
monsieur bricolage smartphone services
plus 12e
tania chaussures smsr ferme la marche à
plus de deux heures des 59 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b
qui joue les faire c'est le poignet le
plus fort alem on aimerait faire bravo
mais père qui remporte cette deuxième
étape c'est la folie sur la plage on va
vivre ça intensément ensemble
[Musique]
oui
et quand on parle
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
là
justement travail
il a gagné la course
m
ceci n'est pas classé
enfin
alors on sait quoi le sentiment là eh
ben c'est de la joie
et puis il ce phénomène en sega ils ont
lutté c'était dur mais ils sont arrivés
au bout mais quelqu'un m'a dit tout à
l'heure que c'est la dernière victoire
du frc maintenant deux minots capote est
toujours la note 'aaa' et portiques
gazon
[Applaudissements]
malone a fait que c'est le plan des
supporters de rosette la césar aulas la
rosa était très attendue rosette arrive
de guerre vous êtes second set up quand
même c'est mieux quand même c'est bien
le fait 6 3 et sera prochainement
il reste encore des étapes derrière
je te bats
[Musique]
après
ola olé là honeywell
merci infiniment bravo à tous oui
j'avais perdu sur corner cette arrivée
bref l'ambiance vous êtes fatigué comme
sa bande les muscles sont
diouf donc bon en tout cas merci parce
que nous le public les supporters on est
très heureux vous nous fait beaucoup de
bien tous les jours pour en savoir plus
sur cette étape et savoir comment les
patrons l'ont vécue c'est notre séquence
parole mapipi on donne la parole aux
patrons
[Musique]
c'est vrai aujourd'hui encore bien des
biens on a fait un bon choix de voiles
et
étrange pas par chance on a pris le bon
wagon et
car on a été dépassés je félicite
établissements osait-il ont bien bien
bien bien pied manouvrer tant mieux mais
l'essentiel est de gagner avant parce
que plus on gagne des victoires puis
qu'on a faim alors baissé c'est clair
que ça va être facile pour la suite mais
on est bien
54 54
choix tactique oui bien sûr parce qu'on
voulait contrôler aujourd'hui mais j'ai
vu que mes adversaires et nos bas mais
plus que moi ils n'ont pas ému il m'a
attaqué bon ça c'est ça c'est eux
mais aujourd'hui
on vous l'a juste et quand même parmi
les deux les deux premiers viols
bon on gagne c'est la cerise sur le
gâteau saab était très difficile je
crois qu'on a tout tenté aujourd'hui
mais il était plus costaud que nous ils
ont gagné tant mieux mais bon on a fait
une belle remontée aujourd'hui c'est ça
l'essentiel c'est bon pour le moral
et puis demain on va essayer ça vient me
quelle surface de quoi on avait une 48
m² est ce que c'est un choix stratégique
par rapport au manque de ventes par
rapport aux bourrasques de vent quand
louis qui a eu aussi c'est pas à pas au
bout parce que c'est vrai dans la baie
de st pierre c'était vraiment on avait
vraiment du vent est fort sur 85 de la
faim jusqu'à 60 70 km/heure et c'était
pas facile il fallait tenir
je vous en a fait le bon choix on a fait
le bon choix de voiles pampa on avait
500 m² le vent un peu trop haut niveau
de saint-pierre donc on a préféré que
que le club est salée puisque ce lait
corrigée très difficile bien que l'on
n'atteint aujourd'hui c'est le but c'est
d'être heureux une bonne option
donc la mission accomplie aujourd'hui on
mange quand même je sais pas ce que ça y
est on se repasse deuxième son histoire
soit pas troisième mais aujourd'hui on
grignote et j'étais affairiste et mon
équipage parce que sur la fin le à la
river est très difficile puisque l'étape
était très très longue aujourd'hui yacé
on avait bien peu de dire bon c'est un
peu dommage parce qu'on avait hier mais
bon c'est a dit qu'on allait rattraper
on allait retourner au jeu dizaine qu'on
allait se faire plaisir sur l'eau et
puis avec les formes et les sept
premiers rôles
on avait plusieurs années avec plusieurs
des vêtements aussi à la bête qui avait
tout il ya des atouts aujourd'hui
[Musique]
miam
les deux supporters fervents que nous
avons bien mérité cette petite pause
déjeuner il est clair en poussière je
t'avais promis un petit lambie grillé
chose promise chose due
bon jour pour moi
l'orbit doyen avec la sauce spéciale
me senghor
[Musique]
il soit spécial
robert ryan et bien autant qu'on se
régale avec ce mardi
il y a
didier à laguiole gf1 caraïbes on va
voir comment elles se préparent au
départ c'est un moment crucial de
l'aider
d'avoir accepté notre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marie vague quelques minutes les
derniers ajustements finir d'attaché la
voile en matériel a le cuir
la météo joue des muscles un doctorat en
droit du sport là ils ont enlevé la
vous serez avec trop de mer
d'être devant mais ça n'empêche pas les
2 to the sea hawk est arrivée jusqu'aux
camps bay y aura de quoi faire
non mais la yole près de l'eau on va
finir de la tâche et la voile le dernier
réglage et mathis prépa rues de marbella
[Musique]
du système qui permet de soulager la mer
il ya certains qui s'occupe du mal de la
merde voilà
et
m
y aller là où viennent l'organisation
militaire parce que là christophe
mondial répond ouais ouais y'a pas le
choix y a pas le choix
personne personne n'attend que c'est ce
qu'il a à faire du rythme toujours des
ajustements à faire
[Musique]
je serais toi les vols de secours voilà
s'envole de ce chaos les autres
les banques restent
je sais que
raul ou quelque chose de cet état là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gevrey
rageur
ok magazine ok ok ok on a fait un bon
départ
apparemment nous les soutiens de vous
faire le départ nous satisfaire on a
donné notre le bon départ on a lancé les
plus costauds pour la puissance du vent
et puis on la ressent le bateau les
emplacements pour tous par djabou falla
changement tout de suite parce qu'on va
en fait jamais été démontés pour alléger
la you were williams est ce qu'on peut
revoir les basiques c'est à dire par
exemple qu'est ce qu'on appelle des
mapic les mapipis et les grosses équipes
à jeter les favoris tu vois bain rose
est par exemple voilà ils ont vraiment
plein d'articles ils ont des supporters
c'est vraiment une grosse machine
d'accord moi je serais très intéressé de
savoir comment ça se passe pour omer
prendrait ça tombe bien c'est notre
séquence caméra embarquée du jour entier
yola au coeur de l'équipage le rosaire
[Musique]
en fait les choix de voiles aux ventes
par rapport à la vitesse du vent tout ça
et par rapport à les conditions si on
sait qu'il ya un vent de force 4
pour ce 3 ont fait trois choix choix de
deux pages et la taxe soit la tête pour
aller au charbon
la fosse est détendue nos départs et du
côté de case-pilote
on a pris la tête de la pousse dans les
zones à calmer souvent on enlever les
poils au pour alléger la yole c'est al
aboudi et puis
ah le déballe des dégâts qui pousse à la
bastille mais dans l'ensemble
c'était tout le monde c'était un beau et
fort mais on a quand même bien travaillé
[Musique]
c'est des bonnes bon c'était du vent
arrière c'était du prêt il y avait des
périodes d'accalmies bon c'est tout ce
qu on a l'habitude de faire un jeu s'est
pas fait parce qu'à pas difficile c'est
en conditions idéales 200 m avant la
brûlerie saint piat c'est là on n'a plus
le droit de nous et on a perdu la tête
de la proa qui nous a manqué
trente secondes de vigilance et c'est la
saq linda foot est peut-être la victoire
c'est dommage parce que on est et on
voulait gagner on voulait gagner aux
pêcheurs bon on n'a pas gagné on termine
5e
c'est pas trop mal puis être pire et
voilà dans l'ensemble je pense que
le tout n'est bon projet alors dès
demain on verra que la loi entre en jeu
boncourt a taclé
[Musique]
un des éléments clés de la voilure
c'est ce bambou la vergue et c'est
l'objet de notre rubrique technique
idole du jour on va tout apprendre sur
cet élément
regardez la vergue est
traditionnellement en bambou car il est
souple et robuste
elle est renforcée avec de la fibre de
verre du carbone et de la résine
elles mesurent entre 7 et 14 mètres
selon la taille de la voile et peine
jusqu'à 60 kg le bambou est coupée en
forêt sur ces images de 1997
les courtiers vont le chercher trois
jours après la pleine bulle pour les
anciens c'est le moment où la scène
serait à ses pieds ce qui garantit un
bon séchage et une meilleure solidité
seuls les bambous mal sont choisis car
les ne sont plus rapprochés ce qui
garantit une plus grande résistance
les experts jugent la maturité de la
tige au sont à l'origine utilisé brut
elle est maintenant enduite de fibre de
verre ou de carbone et de résine pour
une plus grande solidité la veille à une
durée de vie de 3 à 10 ans selon la
qualité de fabrication l'entretien et le
nombre d'utilisations le bonbon
consolidées avec du carbone coûte
jusqu'à 2000 euros
sa fonction maintenir la forme de la
voile et régler sa tension l'aderc sert
à tenir le point d'attaché duo de la
voile pour garder sa forme elle permet
d'affiner le réglage de la voilure
creuser quand il ya peu de vent et
arqués quand il ya beaucoup de vent en
cas de mauvaise préparation
cela peut coûter cher en pleine course
[Musique]
pas facile à l'attentisme de demain tu
pars avec l'équipage tu fais la gueule
mais oui mais oui je veux rappeler déjà
juste une petite info et à contresens
vous faut être dans cette direction là
normalement d'accord mais je débute je
débute liliane préfère m'en vouloir
moi j'essaye formidable aujourd'hui nous
ont fait vivre une seconde étape
incroyablement belle des gars qui m'a
fait des six du prêcheur
fraîcheur demain qu'est ce qui nous
attend et surtout pour le savoir on va
se tourner vers notre spécialiste maison
jean prix de notre doc teillol il va
nous décrypter l'étape du jour et nous
dire ce qui attend les yoleurs demain
[Musique]
aujourd'hui deuxième étape riche et un
pêcheur étape palpitante éprouvant pour
les nerfs et les muscles changement le
parcours au début on ne va plus à
l'appel parce qu'il ya trop de vent
après on ne va plus au carbet parce
qu'il ya pas assez de vent pendant toute
la course variable en direction et en
force
et puis émergent le leader félix mérine
surveillance l'on prend la tête de la
course il maîtrise les choses mais il se
fait remonter un petit peu pas rose et
orange ils n'arrivent à gagner cette
étape car une minute dix secondes demain
ce sera t il demain nous longeons la
côte à l'os a l'air simple fraîcheur
c'est le cher il faut passer longer le
carb aimé que des noms que ces gars là
connaissent un petit peu les rafales que
les rafales de ces pierres les accalmies
du carbet après on va à bellefontaine
on va 15 pilotes il faut longer pour
qu'il faut faire de la tactique demain
je sois le voir hyper important encore
plus qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'on va
partir dans un petit temps et puis
arrive est certainement dans du vent et
du doigt mais il paraît qu'on nous a
prévu de la pluie je ne sais pas comment
on va arriver à cette chère
[Musique]
alors milliards donnant fait 3e et
qu'apple les concepteurs d'outils du
prêcheur pour arriver jusqu à schoelcher
c'est une étape habitude une table
classique du tour des yoles un grand
classique qui réservent des surprises et
des difficultés
il va falloir gaudi est ferme et pour
avoir les détails on regarde qu'à placer
le profil de l'étape
[Musique]
troisième étape au prêcheur schoelcher
départ à 10 heures de la place du bourg
du prêcheur vient d'encaisser les
rafales qui descendent de l'appeler
traverser la baie de saint pierre pour
aller gérer ses sautes de vent du carbet
et de bellefontaine où la marque numéro
un sera à l'essai sur tribord ensuite
gérer tous ces vents variables sous
belle fontaine puis sous classes pilotes
avec des sautes de vent d'elliot
l'immobiliser on va goudier ferme là
sous cette partie de la côte pour aller
tranquillement vers la marque numéro
deux membres qui se situe au large de la
pointe des quelques difficultés
pour y arriver parce qu'il va falloir
pour les yoles se positionner de manière
à aborder la descente la dernière petite
partie du parcours qui est le long de la
côte pour aller vers la morgue numéro 3
qui est à quelques encablures de la
ligne d'arrivée qui est sur la plage du
bourg de shell shell
[Musique]
quatre premières votre rendez vous
quotidien consacré au tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui
venez nous rejoindre demain à l'arrivée
à schoelcher
la course sera palpitante et l'ambiance
sera encore une fois très très chaude à
l'arrivée rendez vous tous les jours sur
martinez première à 20h et sur france ô
à 7 35 pour les lève tôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin
m
[Musique]
ok
oh
non
je ne
[Musique]